were you very disciplined as a kid and
was there a set day or moment when you
saw how important discipline was and
decided to do it well as a kid I think I
was for the most part a kid I was not
some extremely disciplined kid I was I
was pretty stubborn when it came to
certain things which may be some kind of
an early immature form of discipline you
know just being hard-headed but I think
as I got older I saw the first thing I
remember along these lines is seeing a
lack of discipline around me I didn't
identify it as people having discipline
I saw like a lack of displays a weakness
I saw drugs I saw alcohol I saw laziness
and I started to get after it a little
bit right a little bit a little tiny bit
but there was no role models there was
no internet there was no guidance ID and
I didn't have the sense to to go to the
library and and find Bob off man's book
how to be held happy healthy and strong
like I didn't know do you I know that
sense to do that and so we did some
basic things you know what I mean some
push-ups you know in the the push-up
workouts that I did when I was 13 years
old or laughable laughable I mean I
think if I did you know a set of 50
pushups
I was corner you know boom I'm the man
right no you are the man 13:50 in and we
did some silly little like kind of
barbell dumbbells circuit training kind
of thing now I always like the military
I recognize that as a some kind of a
train of discipline in there
and I looked up to military veterans I
knew one Marine Corps drill instructor
and if you know anything about Marine
Corps drill instructors so now we're
talking 85
8687 there wasn't any Wars going on but
you know when you're a kid you're just
like no he's a Marine Corps drill
instructor he fit the part he was like
just perfect Marine Corps bow drill
instructor which most marine corps drill
instructors are pretty damn perfect it's
an incredibly incredibly honed job
that's very well choreographed and very
and very structured in it's a it's a
very fine
real tight tight it's a real tight
situation if you're good Marine Corps
drill and I knew one right when I was a
kid and I just like he was like a god
right this guy is a Marine Corps czar in
and of course he had I think he had like
a 68 Camaro
she had a muscle car so yeah it was just
like just the man and so now so I got
that going on and then then then was the
hardcore bands that I started listening
to and they seemed to have some kind of
there was something there right I
recognized something there I recognized
something with Black Flag I recognized
something with bang called slap shot
yeah I recognized something with the
cro-mags and I saw there was something
in there and and I I did I couldn't I
can't I didn't know what it was but it
was some kind of strength right some
kind of discipline was in there I I
didn't put it all together though and
there was no sort of unified way to go
down this path it didn't I didn't find
that I don't know if I found it if it
what it looked like to me you know maybe
you could say that that path was the Boy
Scouts right the Boy Scouts are a
disciplined group of individuals that
learn how to hike in Ponton I mean so
was that it I don't know maybe I didn't
identify that or I didn't have the right
personality because I was kind of non
conformist right a little bit you know a
little bit of a rebel so I didn't put it
all together in I had some little
flashes of like being hardcore were some
of the things I did that would be like
you know kind of getting Africa some
really minor way some some some
minimalistic level of discipline but it
wasn't until I started training in
earnest to join the Navy that I started
to what we could recognize now as
getting after it a little bit you know
it's and again it's nothing compared to
what people do now what definitely not
what you know now we're talking 1989 I
was running through marshes and being
covered in mud and I was swimming in the
ocean and I was doing pull-ups and
push-ups and dips and situps and again
it's nothing compared to what I do now
or even what everybody does now but I
was doing what I could with what I knew
at the time and I didn't really have any
idea of what I or really what people in
general were capable of like I just
didn't know I didn't know I never would
have thought a good pull-up workout is
five hundred to a thousand pull-ups I I
wouldn't have thought that you know for
me I need three sets and pull-ups and I
was gone you know so I just I just
didn't didn't know and I guess I guess
you could say I didn't even have I
didn't know to even explore those those
outer limits of what I was capable of
you know which is a bummer
now also you gotta remember I didn't
even know another person that did
pull-ups like there wasn't like pull-up
bars around it wasn't you know I'm out
in the woods somewhere
in the woods in New England there's no
pull-ups people people aren't like hey
how many folks can do I never heard that
question and I didn't know anybody that
swam in the open ocean I didn't know
anybody that did push-up workouts right
I don't know I was just in the sticks
and so when I joined the military I was
a blank slate really for all practical
purposes and it was really easy they say
you do this this is what you do and you
get advanced this is what you do to be
ready this is what you do
and I realized very quickly that the
harder you worked that the more
disciplined you were the easier your
life was the easier your job was easier
day was the easier physical activities
would get and when I got to the teams
and really going through buds when
you're going through bulletins when I
finally met guys that were going to buds
and we started doing 100 pull-ups and we
started doing 150 pull so we started
doing 200 pull-ups to work out and then
it was like oh wow you can do a lot of
stuff that was getting ready to go to
buds and you go to buds and you know you
realize that you that people it's not
this this individual like spiritual
awakening like no you just realize hey
you can do a lot of pull-ups people can
it's not that big of a deal and
everybody knows you can find that on the
you don't need you go to buds to figure
that out you can figure that out just
I'm telling you right now you know
they're mean and all you need is to have
that knowledge but I continue to realize
that being disciplined all these things
waking up earlier and working hard and
training hard and keeping your gear
squared away and studying the material
that we were supposed to know I realized
that that work that discipline made life
easier and it made us freer made me free
and the more time I spent in the teams
the more this came embedded in my head
and not only as an individual that I
realized this but I realized this very
quickly we're not very quickly but as
soon as I started moving in the
leadership positions I realized that the
more disciplined a squad was or the more
disciplined double-teaming was the
better that squatter that platoon was
going to be and that's kind of where
will the evolution mmm the evolution of
it
process that I'm finally I don't know if
it finally about it right now it's
starting to become clear where the whole
you know you're gonna pay the price
you know at some point you're gonna pay
the price for your actions so if you're
gonna prep it like let's say I'm gonna
get in shape right you committing to
working out everyday that's you paying a
certain price like this didn't having
the discipline to do it you're gonna pay
the price we cannot really it's not
comfortable working out hard every day
it's not comfortable you're gonna pay a
little price right there the next day or
the you know in regards to the results
of that workout you're not paying the
price you're reaping kind of rewards
right or you cannot pay the price early
with the workout and stuff you still got
it that tab is still outstanding so when
you balance do yeah so when it comes
results time there that's that's when
you're gonna pay your little price there
your body your health whatever at some
point you're gonna have to pay a price
okay now or pay later yeah man so pay
now pay now you get way more benefit
because like no one remembers well we do
some of us do we I don't remember and
take pleasure in remembering the time I
skip that workout because I wasn't
feeling like doing it you know like that
doesn't provide a sense of pleasure in
my life to think back on those days you
know yeah not good and at the same time
when I think of like the detriment of
doing the workout when I didn't feel
like it that doesn't that's not a bad
memory to me you know when I do think
back of like and or think even now if
like the result of being in better shape
than the you know the average person or
we're going to do this with not gassing
or whatever bringing in all the
groceries at one time let's face it
that's something that is a sense of
pleasure that I have the freedom to be
able to do that one I what I want you
know yeah you know what else is
interesting about this and sometimes I
hear this and you did this a couple
times tonight right people go well yeah
but your jock
like as if I'm as if I'm not a normal
person
but I'm not but yeah but I'm saying like
you know I just kind of went through
like this story in in its paints a
pretty clear picture that I'm a pretty
normal person yeah
right yeah it's pretty normal but I made
decisions along the way that maybe
weren't normal and that maybe open the
doors to being a little bit not normal
yeah but their choices that you can make
so so I'll have this with my kids too or
you know who else sometimes I'll have
them I would have friends will say that
would say you know well yeah you're
that's you
you know like I'd say no to me if you
want to win this fight for instance you
want to win this fight man you got it
but you got to do this you got to get
after this you got any well you know
it's not that easy and in that's me
that's what you would do but you're
you're you and that's you know it's
almost like yeah it's unachievable yeah
it doesn't doesn't apply to me and my
kids will say that to me you know my
kids and I think it's actually a pretty
big detriment that they think that I'm
not that that oh I do it but but that's
because I'm me and I'm you know it's
like I'm not true it's not true and so
you know occasionally I have I hear
people say that and I go man this isn't
like I guess it's kind of like what we
were talking about the other day with
someone saying oh oh that's a good
picture you took what kind of camera did
you use well it's kind of like that I'm
like you know oh I wake up early it
doesn't it's not just because I'm just
giddy that way yeah yeah or I work out a
lot odhh it's because you're super
motivated right like that was gifted
yeah I just am born motivated right no
actually I'm a person you know and I
grew up you know person yeah and so but
it makes it very clear that these are
just choices you can make and you can
after it totally true and I would say
that it does when I say one well any
time I would say consciously and
meaningfully say well that's you is if I
would be talking about a way of
achieving like the same thing like you
would do it this way I would try to do
it this way kind of thing if I was
confident that I could get the results
you know whatever that is but what when
did I say today about you're sleeping
yeah you you can do the four hours or so
more so than you can do the four hours
sleep and still function I meant you're
into the four hours five hours sleep
thing yeah which is cool but and I
realize there are some genetic points in
there I believe right yeah I believe
that there are some genetic points in
there I believe there are some genetic
points and in everything right and I've
told you this I have one of my daughters
who is most similar to me both
physically and mentally sleeps about the
same as I do if not less yeah one of my
other daughters who is most physically
and mentally well physically more like
my wife she sleeps a lot yeah and so
there's a and my wife sleeps more than I
do and so there is a genetic component
to it I believe in I've read articles
and people send me a Twitter articles
all the time oh you're one of these you
know fast sleepers that 2% of the
population all this stuff and I'm just
saying okay yeah that's great but then
people say oh well you just work out
every day cuz you're super motivated or
you just train jiu-jitsu all the time
because you're just super motivated it's
like okay right yeah well you know what
great great great yeah yeah I think
you're absolutely correct and even with
the sleeping thing that is like because
okay ultimately yeah you don't have to
sleep as much as the next person sure
that's an advantage just because you
have more time that's it it's not like
you know someone would would be like hey
other than that reason be like hey it's
cooler or it's somehow more beneficial
for me to sleep five hours rather than
my normal eight like so I mean that put
it this way someone wants to choose
to sleep for hours just because you do
it that's kind of weird yeah now that
being said what's awesome is there are a
bunch of people on on the interwebs a
bunch of badass troopers that have I
retweet almost all these because people
go hey you know I'm I lost 32 pounds
mm hey I lost 42 pounds
hey I you know did my first squat today
with 300 pounds suits and there's no
difference in what they were doing
before and what they're do now
fundamentally in their in their jeans or
their or their physiology what they did
is they decided to make these decisions
they decided that they were gonna go out
they decided they were gonna step up
their game they're gonna decide they're
gonna wake up early they decide they're
gonna clean up their diet they decided
they were gonna get after it and when
they do that all of a sudden boom
results and you know what you fast
forward like six months and people go
well you just do that because you're
super motivated anything that we fell be
thinking you don't know I'm not I'm a
person you know and I choose to get
after it you know I recommend you all
choose to get after it and I encourage
stay in it you know what it's not easy
it's not easy
there's the nagging weakness that is
pulling you down you know you gotta shut
that thing down